look if if we if we're like just being
reckless i'll [ __ ] do gummy bears
about my house oh yeah i'm [ __ ] nuts
i'm nuts
[ __ ] nuts fruit and a salad you know
these people go give me the salad with
the uh the raisins and the mandarin
oranges we've never had mandarin orange
or strawberry pecan and a [ __ ] salad
no i'm not i don't buy that i don't dig
it
you're uncivilized no
they live a little that salad's like
mcdonald's civilized come on you can
live a little a little asian chicken
salad with some mandarin orange i like
asian i like chicken i like mandarin
oranges but not together
yeah well sounds like segregation
i don't care for it i grew up with
plates with a little
little sections in my day we [ __ ] we
we separated them and we ate them all we
got all our nutrients yeah but we'd have
to do it together why do you think there
was a chinatown a little italy a harlem
a korea town a curry
hill curry hill whoever came up with
that was clever curry hill
murray hill
well i do think um yeah i'm a big fan of
uh
the right toppings a little eminem's on
there is fun oh little m m's i'll tell
you another thing ice cream in a movie
theater is fun because you're on the
time you're on a time crunch
yeah you're like this is yeah you
brought ice cream in the movie guess
what you gotta [ __ ] hurry up before
it melts good point some people will
threaten you they go you want to be too
quick you know you gotta you gotta eat
that or you get ice cream soup and
you're like oh what a punishment
a soup of ice cream that sounds pretty
it's like chicken noodle but ice cream
oh no it might become a milkshake
yeah these motherless [ __ ]
they try to tell you to not
oh you gotta hurry up guess what it's
gonna be okay
either way it's a chilled uh bisque
of uh ice cream yeah
a chocolate chip bisque sounds pretty
good
but you don't want to get a cone that's
an amateur move because now you're in
the dark
you got [ __ ] all over your fingers you
look like a hard disagree i disagree
cone in a theater oh yeah you're
stressed out yeah you can't relax yeah
why why get a what get why lick it
straight directly when you could get
another step in there and get a spoon
talk about civilized what about a
i want my vagina like it's a [ __ ] i
don't want any extra steps
give it to me
peters can we get a gift for these
motions please
give me give me give me a cone i mean i
eat my cone like this
the old swat cone huh i get it
yeah i dip my nose in it
i do the nose trick too
why not you know it's right there
sometimes i even need it like this
i go slowly
this is a bonus app two manhattans have
really kicked in i think could a good
t-shirt really seem sick
i wish you left a little more you know
what [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm getting more
myself hey
you know it's uh
five o'clock something more to see guys
join the patreon right now at
patreon.com we might be drunk get on the
after party i think i just broke this
there you go
you get emails tell us your wrecks your
jokes your drinks we'll open boxes
you're missing out folks all the good
stuff's on the patreon tell a friend
you